joe burrow getting ready for 2021
recovering from the torn acl
all indications have been positive chris
but as we've discussed multiple times
recently until he's out there playing
we don't know how it's all going to turn
out
for joe burrow will he be as effective
as he was before he suffered that injury
let's hear from zach taylor head coach
of the cincinnati bengals talking about
joe burrow
as he gets ready for year two
been it's been fun to watch him because
he looks good throwing the football you
know obviously he can't do all the
movement stuff that
he'll be doing you know once the season
rolls around but i'm just watching him
throw the football it's the same old joe
he looks better every single day i see
him you know there's a little more
movement there
but certainly the distant stuff is is
something that's uh
not off limits for him right now and so
i know he's just trying to get really
acquainted with some of these receivers
and get some extra throws in and that's
been good to see
hey uh look important year for zach
taylor
not as important for joe burrow from the
standpoint of his long-term career right
but
taylor's got it taylor's got to do
something to reverse this funk the
bengals have been in and yes last year
burrow's injury helped contribute to the
tailspin but
the record is not good through two years
third year for taylor
is going to require burrow and a lot of
guys to get it done at a high level
to keep taylor on the right side of the
employment line for the bengals chris
yeah i would think so i don't know what
that would take either that that's to me
i mean
you know you got to be realistic i think
if you are ownership of the cincinnati
bengals and everything like that too
i mean i don't think you can
realistically look at it and go
i expect our roster to win the division
this year
i mean that at least to me so i don't
know mike like i just ask you like what
what what does he have to do you think
just like off the top of your head
i know it's june 2nd here but like what
do you think record wise he might have
to do
to save his job i don't think it's
realistic to say like oh he's got to go
to the playoffs i i don't not from with
the team he took over the division he's
in and all of that
with the young quarterback and all that
so i just wonder what the
you know the line of demarcation is
there i think the main thing is he's
just got to avoid
a disaster right whatever disaster would
count as because
as we've discussed in the past the
bengals
do not like to pay coaches to not
work and you know we
a lot of times you don't know the
details of a contract and you never will
know the details until for example
a guy gets fired after three years and
it turns out that only the first three
years of his salary
were guaranteed i remember when they
fired marvin lewis he had a year left on
his contract
i was stunned wait a minute they don't
like to to have buyouts oh it turns out
that the next year the last year was a
team held option so they didn't know him
anything so that's the key if they owe
him anything
for 2022 it would have to be
2 and 15 3 and 14
to get zach taylor fired this year i i
really think that
if he has money owed to him in 2022 i i
i
think i'm i'm with you i think it would
have to be i feel the same way
as as long as they're in the fight you
know they're not a pushover
you know they're they're somewhat
relevant to a degree
i i would think that yeah that zach
taylor has a chance to
you know buy buy another gear uh as far
as him coaching the cincinnati bango's
football team but we'll see
i mean you know they did some good
things in the draft free agency but like
we've stated the division's really good
and now you got to beat up quarterback
and dealing with that you know they're
trying to figure out their offensive
line and everything there
so there is some question mark certainly
and some like unproven
you know commodities still so there's a
lot a lot of work to be done there in
cincinnati
the over under from points bet for
bengals wins this year is six and a half
i still think they could go
six and eleven maybe even five and
twelve once you get down to
four and thirteen it just looks horrible
my best to make sure the total is 17.
it's not easy to get used to
four or less that's when i think he's
got a problem yeah i i think you're
right because like when you see
four and 12 or four and 13 or anything
like that
you just your first thought is when you
see that number on the team's record you
go they were a disaster this year
they're at a disaster that's really the
thought and and
it kind of carries on to the offseason
and why they're drafting where they're
drafting and those type of issues so
yeah i i'm i'd probably say
i don't know in a year like this he
might have to get seven wins it might
have to be a seven and ten type record
which still sounds so freaking weird to
say that holy cow there were
there were rumors yeah late last year i
know remember but he was out
yeah and the bengals felt compelled to
issue his statement
the day after the regular season ended
announcing that he was coming back
which just legitimized the fact that the
talk was out there when does that ever
happen that you have an affirmative
statement from a team that the coach is
going to be back coaches under contract
for the next year so
it's definitely there hi i'm mike tarico
and thanks for watching
make sure to hit subscribe for the
latest news and highlights
from nbc sports